خطير شاب
الميدانيه تضاف حرب الكنائس في الصراع
القائم بين كيف وموسكو بعد ان اعلنت
الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه الاوكرانيه السماحه
لكنائسها بالاحتفال بعيد الميلاد في ال 25
ديسمبر الاول بدلا من السابع يناير كانون
الثاني مثل ما هو معتاد في التجمعات
الارثوذكسيه
[موسيقى]
الان في عائلتنا لن نتحدث الا باللغه
الاوكرانيه
بتقاليدها واعيادتها ويذبحوننا
اكثر من شهرين في قبو منزله تحت القصف
الروسي قبل ان تقع المدينه في ايدي الجنود
الروسي
ولا اريد ان اكون مع رجال الدين يحتقموننا
ويتمنون موتانا
الامبرياليه الان بعدما احرارا يمكننا
القول اننا مستقلون عن كنيسه موسكو
اولادهم في جبهات القتال ولكي يخلصهم من
حرب تكاد تنهي عنها الاول دون اي مؤشرات
لتهدئه او حوار